welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the final
preparations for the state funeral of
queen elizabeth ii
king charles iii will host president
biden along with 500 other heads of
state and foreign dignitaries at
buckingham palace tomorrow on friday the
king and his siblings including princess
anne held a silent vigil around their
mother's coffin in westminster hall
today the queen's eight grandchildren
will do the same
overnight mourners near windsor castle
witnessed a rehearsal of the queen's
burial process the funeral has been
planned for decades with details
especially important to the queen
roxanna saberi has more from london
the last century has witnessed powerful
moments of public grief from the
assassination of a president to the
passing of an icon and the death of a
princess
but on monday in london a nation and the
world will say a final farewell to the
woman who outlived them all at queen
elizabeth's state funeral how much
rehearsing is going into it the queen's
funeral has been rehearsed almost
annually every year and
for many many years
britain's last state funeral was in 1965
for winston churchill who led the
country through world war ii winston
churchill was much loved by the british
public but
the queen is in a different stratosphere
to winston churchill and i think
her state funeral will reflect that
troops from commonwealth countries will
take part in a procession being
rehearsed around the clock that former
bbc royal correspondent wesley kerr
predicts will draw at least a million
people to the streets everything has
been done to enable the largest number
of people and there seems to be an
insatiable demand
to see her late majesty's coffin but in
a very dignified way
some elements of a state funeral follow
tradition members of the royal navy will
tow the queen's coffin on a gun carriage
a ritual that began in 1901 when horses
pulling queen victoria's funeral
carriage panicked and sailors stepped in
but we'll also see personal touches
choreographed by queen elizabeth herself
in this covid traumatized world doctors
and nurses will march on monday and the
queen's strong faith will resonate
throughout they'll be her favorite hymns
there'll be particular prayers
come in to honor a monarch who met 13
u.s presidents and visited over 100
countries around 500 heads of state and
foreign dignitaries are expected putting
diplomacy front and center expecting it
to go off smoothly our government is
pretty good at figuring out who can sit
next to who and who can't
britain's security services have to
figure out how to keep them safe this is
the biggest policing operation uk
policing has ever undertaken the weight
of responsibility now rests with the
metropolitan police service
the day will start at westminster hall
but will end quietly in windsor at st
george's chapel where the queen will be
laid to rest with the man she could no
longer live without
for cbs saturday morning roxanna seberry
london
stay with us and stay with cbs news for
full coverage of queen elizabeth's
funeral on monday morning our live
coverage begins at 5 30 eastern right
here on cbs and on the cbs news
streaming network